uh so it's a Jupiter light environment
so I'm not sure if you if you're
familiar with Jupiter light but it's a
version of a Jupiter lab notebook
setting that runs directly into your
brother so it means that there is no uh
no need to install anything on your
machine uh it will automatically uh
compile every dependencies required on
the fly directly in Firefox or Chrome or
whatever uh internet browser you use
so um however the limitation of this is
that it's a bit slower than usual uh so
you might want to run at least the the
first three cells while I'm talking uh
because those cells can can take a run a
way to run so you can uh press shift
enter uh and then they should run like
this it's not too slow
actually uh just checking that I do not
have the output yeah yes it's clean okay
oh yeah and if you already have the
output you can uh you can go to the edit
menu and clear clear click clear all
output here uh so that you can uh you
can
reproduce on oh sorry made a
mistake uh you can reproduce the result
on the fly on your own machine if you
want um and especially if you want to
follow for the exercises it's important
to to execute the The Notebook on the
Fly uh as we go through
it all
right um so before we actually start
with the the actual material so I I
would like to to run a quick
poll uh so I will publish it in the
uh uh in the in the uh in the poll menu
and you should be able to to run it and
we will see basically a bit about uh the
audience background so I would like to
know whether or not you're familiar with
psyit learn in particular specific
questions to to gouch your familiarity
with the machine learning and psych
learning python there is the first
question uh second question about uh
whether people in the audience are also
our programming experts or data
scientist experts and if you know a bit
about survival analysis the topic the
statistical topic of today the third
question and then three questions
about your background so I was limited
in the number of options so I had to
make choice but
uh so we just run that bit for for a bit
longer all right so it's interesting to
see
that
uh we got uh more than a third of people
are uh experts enough in psychic learn
very few people from the art
community and uh some people were
already familiar with the topic I want
to introduce today and most people come
from the industry apparently uh some
students and very little uh academics
all
right uh so I will leave the the poll on
so that people can continue there but
hide it
from
okay uh so the topic today is uh
survival analysis using the the python
uh the python
tools uh so in particular we will speak
about psyit learn uh uh the lifelines
library uh in the abstract I also
mention psyit survival which is some
kind of extension of psychon for
survival analysis unfortunately because
we decided to use Jupiter light we could
not actually run uh Sayid survival in
Jupiter light because of compiled
dependencies uh packaging issues uh but
uh you can have a look later at at at
the C survival website and based on this
tutorial you will understand exactly how
to use it it's going to be very similar
and uh furthermore uh there is a a small
library that we we include did a copy of
that Library it's an experimental
library that we call hazardous but it
has now its own GitHub repository this
is an old copy that we have here uh
where we put our experimental code for
survival analysis and I when I say we
it's van Mader and I we are both uh
engineers at inria uh working on Psychic
learn and related libraries and and a
while ago we started to invest to
investigate this survival analysis topic
and and uh we thought that we could uh
try to improve uh upon what was already
available in the python ecosystem by
implementing our own experimental method
in this little Library so right now it's
very limited uh but we plan to expand it
over the over the future and we know
also that there are some uh uh some some
limitations or statistical bias in the
existing models and in Ste metrics that
we put there so but we we plan to
improve that over the the future years I
would be happy to discuss about those
limitations later in the questions at
the end of the session if you if you're
interested um all right so let's get
started so hopefully you have the first
three uh sales that could run
successfully if it's not the case feel
free to to report any eror in the chat
and if it's easy to fix I can
give you instructions if it's not easy
to fix you will have to follow on my
script on my screen hopefully it runs
for
everyone okay so the goal of this
tutorial is to introduce uh what we call
right censored uh time to even data uh
and why naive machine learning
regression models uh cannot deal with
this uh this kind of right Andor time to
data uh then we will will study how the
capan mayor estimator is able to to deal
with this kind of data in a
unconditional manner we which means that
we just model a distribution of an
outcome variable y uh irrespective of
any input features X first just modeling
the target variable y alone and then we
will see how to do predictive survival
analysis meaning that we we want to
estimate a conditional distribution y
given X and so for this you can use Cox
proportional hazards that we will
introduce today survival Forest that are
implemented in psychic survival but
unfortunately we can could not get them
to work uh in in this notebook uh but uh
you will find online references to them
and uh gradient boosting incidence which
is a new model that we we
developed uh that directly optimizes the
the the objective function that we were
interested in
which we call the integrated Briar score
it's one way to evaluate the the quality
of productive survival model there is an
alternative metric which is also
interesting which is called c Index and
we also quickly introduce what it is and
then uh we will compare all those
methods uh on some statistical some
synthetic data sets uh and this way we
will be able to assert whether or not
they are they are good uh
uh and we will also try to inspect a bit
what they do Under the Hood by looking
at the partial dependence blot or
permutation feature import actually
partial dependence blot I think we
removed it from from this uh notebook
because uh it was problematic but
anyway um so what is our right sensor
time to event data uh so the here we are
interested in a in a family of problem
where uh we have individuals that can
experience they are at risk we say and
they can experience a specific kind of
event that we are particularly
interested in uh so I give examples here
below the the graph so for instance in
the clinical or medical setting you want
to study uh the likelihood of patients
of D dying of cancer over a specific uh
the time horizon or uh on the contrary
recovering from some disease uh uh for
instance when they take a
treatment um so those are could be the
the event of Interest either dying or
surviving um in a predictive maintenance
setting you would be interesting in
modeling the the time it takes for a
machine to fail and or to operate
without failure for a long time in
Insurance setting
uh you might be interested uh in
modeling the time it takes to uh a
customer to file a claim uh for a
portfolio of insurance
contract uh in marketing setting uh many
people are interested in modeling
churning events so when a subscribe user
of a service would go away stop the
subscription and and go away and leave
the service to either use a competing
service or just stop using it uh or or
the opposite would be if you have free
customers you use a free account uh
whether the the event of Interest could
be to switching to a paying account with
a
subscription uh so that's also a
different kind of of event that you
might be interested in to model or
Economist could could be interested in
modeling the time it takes for
unemployed people to find a new job and
maybe study the statistical dependency
of this event to covariates such as uh
age or training or gender depends on
what you want to
study
um uh Alo show economic background and
so on uh so in all those settings uh the
the target variable that we want to
predict is a duration uh between a
reference time that we call t0 and uh
and so we measure the different the
difference between the t0 particular
time of reference and and the time where
we observe the event and usually uh we
cannot observe for an infinite amount of
time and wait for the event to appear so
we we usually have a a fixed observation
window and so for some of the people uh
for instance uh the individuals that
enter the study
later uh the the events might not be
observed before the end of the study
because not necessarily all the people
join the study at the same time or the
observation period at the same time but
so they will have different reference
time T Zer but what we measure is just
the duration between the time we start
to observe them and the time and the
moment where they experience the event
or the end of the observation time and
so if the individual do not experience
the event before the end of the
observation period we say that they are
sensor which means that they are they
stayed even free
until the the the end of the observation
period And this is actually the the the
root of the problem for for survival
analysis because it's very often the
case that in the settings that I I
presented previously a significant
fraction of the individuals of our
training set or even the evaluation Set
uh will stay even free until the end of
the observation period so we cannot
really predict the the time to event for
those because we cannot actually model
the time for for those because we
actually didn't record it because we
didn't wait long enough for for to be
able to observe the
event so so when we when we deal with
this situation
um we have several options that will
present later uh and all the naive
options to try to fit this uh problem
the statistical estimation problem into
a traditional regression problem that we
could solve traditional machine learning
models if you use it navely for instance
discarding the the sensor the
individuals uh then you would introduce
a significant Bas uh assuming that you
have a significant fraction of your
database that that is censored for
instance if you have 30% of of your
observation that are sensored then it
becomes a problem if you just have one
or two% of the people that are censored
probably that you can treat it as a
traditional regression and wouldn't be a
big problem but in a clinical setting
for instance a modeling survival it's
very often the case that you have 80% of
the of the patient that could be
sensored it can happen
okay and so and just yeah so we will see
why we we need to De with that so the
way we represent this kind of data uh
and in particular the the outcome
variable uh is uh to So In traditional
regression
I would just be a continuous variable
but here in time to event regression
with sensoring we have to use a more
complex variable y it will it will have
two components two columns basically if
you use a pandas data frame uh one would
be a binary event indicator zero means
that the event was not observed and one
that the event was observed so zero
means sensoring basically and uh the
second column that we call D would be
the the minimum time between the the the
true event uh time
distribution uh that we we could observe
if we had an infinite uh uh time window
uh which is never the case in practice
and C which you can also consider a
random variable which is the the
duration of your observation window so
basically if C is smaller than than T it
means then uh the the event is sensored
and so you cannot record the you just
record the
duration for that individual to stay
even free uh surviving let's say but you
cannot uh record the the time the actual
time to event of
interest um so you but it's still
interesting to record that you waited
for a significant amount of time and
that the event did not occur in that
time it's still interesting information
even if it's not the the real
information that you're interested in
it's it's still data and you should not
discard it okay um so here we will see
an example so it's stored in a parket
file uh so it's a data set that was uh
generated from a uh a Python program
that simulat uh a TR a fleet of trucks
operating with drivers and the trucks
have different characteristics the
drivers have different experience Level
Training and so on and um and we have
some uh Risk rules that control those
event and then we sample from that that
simulator uh for for a fixed observation
period whether or not uh trucks and
their drivers would experience uh a
failure event so it's a some kind of
predictive maintenance setup and so here
um those are the recorded uh uh things
for the individual so each individual is
one truck with one driver basically um
and so this would be a number of uh the
duration measured in days and if it's
true it means that uh the track failure
has been observed at that after that
duration and if it's false it mean it
means that we did not observe long
enough to observe the event but we
waited for for 125 days for instance for
this one without observing the event for
for that specific truck because we
started to record stuff about this truck
later than for the others uh for
instance because it's a new truck that
was deployed in operation later than the
others
okay um so we have to deal with this
target variable both in the training
data and in the test data
okay so why is it a problem to uh uh why
is it different to to train a predictive
model for for time to event regression
models uh so we we could try to to
discard the fact that uh that they are
censored uh element and just for
instance compute a descriptive statistic
such as the mean time to event or the
median time to event only on the uh only
on the uh the tracks that experience the
event okay so suppose we we want to
quantify the the the median time to
event uh one way to deal with the
sensoring would be just to uh ignore the
sensored records okay but if we do that
we will introduce a bias so here we
comput it on on our sensor data set but
just by filtering using pandas so this
is a pandas data frame so we use the
query function to filter on the event
colum and just keep the rows that have a
true value for that column and then we
extract the the matching values for the
duration column and we compute the both
the mean and the median okay this is U
just Tas
operations
um and so the the average would be uh
little less than 600 days
uh on average and the median time will
be four 43 days uh and alternatively
what we could do to deal with this
sensor data is that for all the the the
the people the individuals for which we
did not observe uh the event we could
say that maybe they will never observe
it and we just set an arbitrary large
value of the event time which would be
for instance the maximum duration that
we have observed in the training set
it's it's a bit arbitrary but some kind
of arbitrary fe uh feature imputation
missing value imputation but instead of
doing it in the feature in the CET we do
it on the
target uh and it's completely arbitrary
so it's probably meaningless but that's
an alternative way to deal with this
problem which is also naive and if we do
that we have a very significant value
which is much larger which is kind of
expected because we replace the missing
values by very large
values uh and so uh the mean would be uh
almost twice that the original number
and the median also also large value
okay uh in our case uh we we get we
extracted the data from a simulator we
sampled it from a simulator so we could
run the this Simulator for a much longer
time and since the the risk to
experience a failure is never zero in
our in our problem setting we can wait
long enough so that we can observe the
the the failure time for all the
individuals in our f
okay so we have a second parket file
where we run the S the simulator for
much longer until we observe the event
for all of them and this will give us
the ground Truth uh for the number that
we are interested in and so I can
execute this and you see that the true
numbers for the the mean value and the
median value are
870 and
735 so you see it's in between the the
two too naive way uh that we used
previously okay but in practice we can
never do that in in a real life setting
because uh we can never wait for an
infinite number of uh long time we we we
want to run the statistical analysis
without waiting too long okay so we will
have sensor point in our in our data and
so we have to deal with this limitation
so it's just to illustrate that the the
ground truth is between those two
extreme naive uh ways of dealing with
the sensor data okay so how to do that
um so it really depends on what we want
to do uh so if we are interested in
modeling for instance the true mean or
median time to event of Y independent of
Any coent X we can use what we call um
an unconditional or a descriptive model
uh and so uh the for survival analysis
this is
typically achieved using what we call
the capline mayor estimator that is
implemented in the lifelines library for
instance so here it will only model what
happens in the the Y random variable
irrespective of any covariates for
instance descriptors of the trucks um
that you might have uh at your disposal
okay but if you're interested in uh
making individualized prediction for for
different
individuals uh with different values of
X and and find
uh uh estimate the distribution of Y
given X basically then you could use
what's called predictive survival models
such as Cox proportional hazards which
is implemented in lifelines survival
Forest which is implemented in psychic
survival or our gradient boosting
incidence model that we implemented in
the Hazardous
Library uh then there is uh an extension
of survival analysis which is called
competing risk analysis that I will not
describe in detail today but it's
important to know that it exists and it
it happens whenever you are in situation
where you have potentially one of event
of interest but there are competing
events that can appear and once they
appear the original events of interest
that you're particularly interested in
will never appear again will never occur
for that individual for instance if you
are uh during cancer cancer research you
might want to study the impact of
karates such as the age of patient or
whether or not they they took a
treatment to survive uh a specific kind
of cancer for instance uh but those
individual during the time of the study
could also experience other diseases or
Road accident or whatever and die from
another cause that is not cancer the and
if the do they will never die of cancer
as a result so that would introduce
another kind of statistical bias which
is different from sensoring uh and so
you need specific methods so when you
deal with Computing risk analysis you
both have sensoring and Computing risk
and so you have two kinds of problems to
deal with to avoid
introducing time to
progression so for this there are other
estimators for for instance the Jon
estimator with that implemented in the
lifelines library or we could also adapt
our new estimator called gradient
boosting incidence to to
modelers in a predictive setting meaning
given X okay all right but this we will
we won't have time to to cover that
today but uh if you're interested you
can have a look at the documentation in
lifelines or or or Hazard Library also
that some
explanations okay let's start with the
simpler model so the UN conditional
setting meaning that we only model the
distribution Y without X for now to to
keep things simpler so uh we are going
to use the capan mayor estimator and
this estimator is an an estimator of
what we call the uh the survival
function the survival function takes as
an argument different values of time
Horizon so possible time durations that
we are interested in for instance when
you're uh uh
clinicians you might want to know uh the
the survival
time the the probability to to for our
patients to survive at least uh 28 days
for instance or one year or five years
for instance so you you might have
specific time Horizons of interest and
you can vary that Horizon and you want
the probability of the the event to that
of interest to occur so this is the the
the duration of the of staying even free
uh after a specific time Horizon of
Interest small T okay of course uh the
the true T here we never observe it
because we have sensored data so in
practice the Y that we have is not the
the T that I I have here
because what I explained earlier okay so
you have the the Y with the two columns
instead and so we cannot directly
observe the
realization of of t or at least some of
them are
sensored okay so one way to deal with
the sensoring is to is to compute this
estimate that you can compute from data
with sensoring and it will be an unbi
estimate of the true survival
probability so this formula basically
iterates over all the uh the the events
that you observe in your data set so
each of the eyes here are individual and
TI is the time for of the event for
individual I that actually experience
the event so without sensoring okay so
for only for people we actually
experience the event and at the same
time you can you can also record the
number of
individual
uh
um uh that have experienced the event at
that time okay and NY is the number of
individual that are still at risk of a
Time ti so this is discard discarding
the people who had censor the event
before TI okay and so you can run this
formula uh but it's a cumulative product
over your full data set and those
numbers those three numbers you can
compute them uh by taking account the
fact that some people have experienced
sensoring or not before a specific time
and and you do that for all the possible
times that you observe in your data set
okay uh so this is this is the important
sentence individuals that were censored
before Ty are no longer considered at
risk at Ty so uh in particular this NY
here is affected by the people who were
censored before t Okay um so it's not a
predictive model because it's uh it's
not conditional it doesn't take any side
uh information from a feature Matrix X
okay so but it's still interesting as a
descriptive model and from this we can
compute an average an expected value for
for the the real time without sensoring
or a quantile estimate for instance for
uh how long it takes for
50% of your population at risk to
experience the event okay so with this
model you can you can compute those two
point quantities for instance or you can
also pick up uh a reference time Horizon
for instance 5 years and estimate the
probability of survival at five years so
to do this in Python you can import
capan May capan mayor fter from
lifelines uh it's not exactly following
the psych learn API so it's slightly
different
API um so you need to pass it when at
fit two arguments the durations and the
events observed so this is the Boolean
column of our data set and this is the
continuous value
from the second column from our data set
and uh it will run the analysis it will
compute basically this formula very
quickly and then uh we have the survival
probabilities uh at each possible time
so those are the times uh the order
times that were uh observed in the data
set and for for each of those times we
have the estimate of survival
probability so this you see at the end
that it's not
zero uh because of sensoring I will go I
will explain that again
later so okay so instead of having just
a table of number we can use M plot lip
to actually plot uh that
curve uh and so this is the the result
of the cap mayor estimation so it gives
us a single curve the survival curve uh
which start at one at t0 100% of the
population at risk uh is alive has
survived has never experienced the event
and over time as time progress a
fraction of that population will
experience the event and this is the
probability of observing the event uh if
we did not have uh any
sensored individual in in your data set
it will be in this estimate is should be
independent of the sensoring
distribution
basically um unfortunately you see that
it cannot extrapolate beyond the point
the the maximum time that it has
observed in the training set okay so
it's kind of truncated in this way uh it
doesn't try to extrapolate so you could
extrapolate Yourself by saying after
that point everybody survives or after
that point uh you you compute the slope
here and you say the slope is constant
and actually better than the slope would
be the hazard rate I will explain later
what it means would stay constant and
then you use that to EXT extrapolate the
the survival beyond that point but the
Caplan mayor estimator itself doesn't
try to do anything clever it just say I
cannot answer after that point
okay so the
the the the capan Mayon uh cap plan
mayor fitter object from lifelines also
computes uh the median survival time
because this is something frequent that
people are interested in and uh this
corresponds to the time it takes for 50%
of the population at risk so this is
represented by the the red dash line
here to uh experien the events so when
those this horizontal line crosses the
blue line and so you see that it should
be a bit big for uh 750 days and it's
actually computed by in Python and it
says that it's
734 days okay uh since
uh uh no okay I will I stop here uh so
here we just record uh those
um those two values so the the the time
grid that was used by by the Caplan
mayor fitter and for each time point the
Caplan mayor estimate the survival
probability
estimate so here there is the first
exercise but it's not the most
interesting exercise so I will skip it
and we just show the the solutions
directly uh when we wrote this tutorial
it was um meant for another conference
there was a a longer session so I I'm
I'm running a bit faster than what was
already intended so here it's how to
implement uh in Python uh this median
survival time from scratch without using
the Klan
mayor attribute here we just use the the
times and the the K estimate for each
time so there are different ways to to
do that you can use NP search sorted or
CPI interpolate so I would just show you
the the solution uh so you could sort
the values in a reverse order and then
use a search sorted uh uh to find the
the
index uh that that that would match the
closest the target value of 50% those
are probabilities so there there is one
probability between zero and one that is
closest to 50% in in all the the sorted
probabilities um and then we take
the this index and
because we sorted in the opposite
direction we need a minus here so why we
need to sort in in this order it's
because s sorted assumes that we have a
monotonically increasing values in the
first argument and because we have a
survival function it's monotonically
decreasing so we need to just swap the
order uh but then since we swap the
order here we need to put a minus sign
here and then we have the estimate of
the median survival time we can just
round it and that should give us I'm
sorry
I I didn't want to change this okay and
uh and so you see that we have this
value which should be very close to what
lifelines is doing internally okay uh
alternatively we can use an
interpolation function from CPI and so
we will inter inter olate from the space
of
probabilities uh to the space of time
using linear interpolation and then once
we have this interpolation function so
it's a piece-wise linear uh function we
can compute the value at the probability
of
0.5 and and round the result and and see
what we get and we get uh almost exactly
exactly the same here so I'm not sure
exactly why uh Lifeline does something
different but you see it's very it's
very similar
okay uh yeah
okay and finally uh since uh this data
set was generated
from synthetic uh ground truth process
that we know as the author of of this
data set uh we we could run the
simulation for longer so we can use the
unsensored version of the data set and
just compute the median uh on the
duration
column uh and this is the the True
Value and you see that the capan mayor
estimate is very close to that okay just
from a finite sample with sensored
values uh it could
recover uh actually this is also a
finite sample statistic so it's not a
population statistic but this uh value
is independent of the sensoring okay and
so you see that the capan mayor
estimate basically is not affected too
much by the sensoring uh it's very close
Okay contrary to our previous estimate
that we did at the beginning uh if you
recall we had naive ways to to compute
by discarding the sensor data point and
the median was very different okay and
the other one where we imputed by a
large durations is was also arbitrary
different okay uh so you see that cap
mayor is a a sensitive way to deal with
sensoring and it should be a very
independent uh unbiased basically by by
the sensoring distribution all right uh
do you have any questions so far uh feel
free to to ask any question or in the
chat uh apparently
no
okay all right so let's go on
so uh
um let me give you a bit more
mathematical details
uh um so when so far we we mentioned the
sensoring distribu the the survival
distribution um you can also be
interested what in what we call the
hazard rate so the hazard rate is uh
some kind of speed of failure or speed
of experiencing the event uh conditioned
on the fact that we have survived until
the point t a specific point T so uh uh
when time progresses the speed of
failure can
change uh but the it's the the the risk
basically of experiencing the event at
different time Horizons okay so it's
it's defined this way uh so it's the
probability of experiencing of observing
the event at a specific time between T
and and t plus delta T DT so DT DT is a
very small quantity so it goes to zero
uh given the fact that uh
actually the P here should not be there
given the fact that the random variable
T is larger than the the time of
reference okay can I change this
yeah
okay
oops Yeah that's more correct um all
right so uh it's uh it's
equivalent to uh
ft divided by St so St is the survival
function that we defined previously and
ft is the density function of the event
time distribution okay but this one
compared to Lambda T it's a density
function so it's also some kind of
Hazard failure rate but it's in a
situation where we do not consider the
fact that we have
failed remained event free before so
it's a bit weird ft to understand
concretely what it means Lambda T which
is the hazard rate it's much more
natural the speed of failure at a
specific time Horizon given the fact
that we have survived until that time
Horizon okay
uh furthermore we can say we can be
interested in the cumulative incidence
function which is
basically uh the integral of the density
function so the the the the probability
of experiencing the event over time okay
and so this quantity is ever increasing
it's monotonically increasing and it's
basically the complement of the survival
function okay and so ft is the dens is
the density of the distribution of the
event time
and big ft is the integral the
cumulative density function
basically uh when we have Computing risk
it's slightly different it's a bit more
complex but in a binary survival setting
it's it's EAS okay uh we can also
integrate the cumulative hazards uh and
there is a
relationship uh between the cumulative
Hazard and the survival function so it
means that if you can estimate the the
the small Lambda hazards you can then
numerically integrate them and then take
the exponential minus that value and and
recover the survival function so that
would be a way to estimate the the
survival function and then the
cumulative incidence function as well
and if you estimate the survival
function directly in one way or another
you can recover an estimate of the
instantaneous Hazard rate by taking the
time derivative of the survival function
and dividing it by itself so you can run
the math so this relation here it comes
from um differential equation uh so you
yeah it's it's possible to prove all of
this it's you can look at Wikipedia I
think there's the proof
somewhere uh okay so and this is what we
do here so here we have uh because we we
know that um the the data generative
process because we generated the data
from a Python program um so if I go back
to the first cells that we executed
quickly at the beginning here we have
the theoretical hazards uh that where
that are the basically fund when we run
our simulator okay and then we sample
from those hazards to get actually the
the data set in the park file okay so so
to to generate the data the the files
the the event the duration in the parket
file we used the uh the theoretical
hazards and then we we did some random
samping based on that okay
so because we have those theoretical
hazards we can compute the uh the
theoretical survival function aggregated
over all the data points uh in our data
set for all the individuals so I use the
the math equations that uh we did
previously so this is the the time the
time integral a cumulative integral this
and this is minus exponential is the
so you see it's exactly a direct nump
translation of of what I said before and
we we average over all the individuals
in the data set and then we can plot the
results and we can compare to the capan
May estimate and so you see that our
theoretical curve is exactly matching
the K May estimate there is slight
discrepancy here because we have a
finite sample sample we have 10,000
individual uh so with 10,000 individual
it's already very close to the
theoretical the only difference here is
that we have access that to what happens
after what we observed in our training
set so
we we know exactly the ground truth of
what should happen after that okay all
right but this is a confirmation that
the capan mayor estimate is an unbi
estimator of the survival curve all
right so now uh we could try to use the
capan mayor estimator to uh use
information from X to uh predict if uh a
specific feature in X has an influence
on the survival probability uh at
different times okay so let's look at
the the input features
X so they also recorded for each
individual so you see we have 10,000
rows so for the same 10,000 events that
we've recorded we have uh context
information on uh the drivers uh the
kind of trucks that they drove the the
brand the truck model and how often they
would uh they would run the the track
during the observation period on average
okay uh so those are predictive features
or at least possibly productive features
of of the risk okay and they are
actually all productive because we know
the the simulator they are actually all
used to to to derive the hazard rates
and so here I just concatenate with the
outcome Val value so that you you can
see the match between the features and
and and the target
so here uh we can do this uh five
minutes for this exercise so what you
can do is try to to use this data frame
so this data frame uh uh uh here
or um to uh so to pass it as an argument
to this function and in the function
what you can do is uh find for different
brand and so the list of possible brands
is here and you can use
pandas uh to filter this data frame by
brand so to to record only the rows for
a specific brand and compute the capan
mayor estimate exactly what as we did
previously in the previous sales and uh
and then use M plot lib uh to uh to plot
the survival curve for the drivers of
trucks of different brands okay so there
should be
there are actually only two Brands chips
and
robuster those are fake names doesn't
but they have different characteristics
and they should get different survival
cures so try to to do that uh give you a
couple of minutes and just to to get
familiar with the lifeline API so you
can scroll back up to the previous sales
to to
see how we did it on aggregate for the
full population here you try to do it
for two segments of of the population
two partition of the population and then
we'll see how how it looks like in
the if we have different survival
function and feel free to ask question
in the chat if anything is not
clear so I I put a poll also so that I
can collect feedback on whether or not
uh you want me to go on or if you want
more time to do the to complete the
exercise all
right I will show the the
answer sorry if you did not have time to
complete so uh the solution is right
after hopefully you didn't scroll too
quickly um so uh so you can itate over
the brand and filter the data frame by
brand
so that's that's one way to do it you
could also have used the query function
of pendas which I prefer
personally um actually let me do
it you can do query brand equals equal
and then you can reference the python
local variables using the Hat sign
here okay so this should be a slice of
the data frame and for this slice we can
fit a cap Mayer uh estimate then use the
plot function and uh you can normalize
the plot the way you want okay so you
should get
this uh conveniently the plot function
of lifelines also comput uh confidence
interval that should be uh large if you
have a small data set and uh and
significantly a th if you have a a large
data set many data points basically so
here you see that since our data set is
quite large the the confidence interval
is very narrow so we can clearly see
that uh the two uh kinds of
trucks uh have different survival curves
and in particular chips tends to fail uh
much before or significantly before if
you I don't know if you take a specific
line like 40% here you see that there
are almost
two no 100 100 days so several month of
difference in life exp expectancy at
this time okay for for the different
tracks but over time you see that in the
end uh the two Brands tends to fail at
some point and the more you
weight the more the both curves go to
zero basically
and it's interesting here that
Robusta for very long time duration has
tend to be not that reliable whereas it
was much more reliable at the beginning
okay uh all right and so we could
compute the different median time
survival for instance for chips it's
around
750 uh and for or even before this
number and for robust ties significantly
after 800 days or or more 900 days I
don't know exactly uh so you see that uh
one is larger than the average median
time and the other one is smaller than
the average median time so how to to
tell whether our a model uh is good or
not a survival model is good or not uh
there are two metrics that I want to
introduce
they exist more but I found those two
metrics particularly interesting even if
they have their
limitation uh so the first one is called
integrated Brier score or more precisely
time integrated Brier score so if you're
familiar Brier score is proper scoring
rule for a classification model so here
you could consider that uh this model
here is a classifier of survival at
different time Horizon for instance
uh suppose that you consider the
specific time Horizon of 750 days uh
given the the brand uh X as a feature as
an input feature you want to Output the
probability of survival uh and so here
it would be close to 0.5 and for robar
it would be slightly bigger okay and and
you have a binary ATC come which is uh
survived or not and uh and you want a
probabilistic classifier that would
predict survival or not given given the
the brand here U so you you you can use
a classification metric for this if you
consider a specific uh time Horizon okay
but when you want to do that for many
time Horizon all the possible time
Horizon what you can do is compute these
Valu this
classification error metric for all the
times and then compute an average and
this is basically a Time integrated
average of the Brier score uh the the
the concordance index is different in
it's more like a a discriminative metric
for the regression problem so you you
you regress the time for different
individual it takes to to experience the
failure uh and you consider all the
pairs of individuals and if your model
uh uh ranked the pair in the right right
order meaning that the the individual
that failed first was predicted to fail
first compared to the other one uh then
the concordance index should be closer
to one uh if not it should be closer
to.5 like the the random prediction uh
would be. five for for the concerence
index uh so it's a bit similar to The
Rock au but it's for regression you see
because the rock is more like for
classification for binary classification
here it's more like we we do a
regression model where we we predict the
time it takes to experience the event
the expected time it takes to experience
the event and we compare if the the
ordering is correct okay so it's still a
ranking metric but uh in some kind of
time to EV regression setting okay this
is why it has a different name for it's
slightly different from the rock a for
classification we could also have done a
Time dependent Rock Au and it's
perfectly valid way to to evaluate
survival model
and also time integrated Rock a if you
consider the the classification problem
at each time Horizon and then you
integrate over time uh uh my point here
is that the concordance index is just
assessing the ranking power so it's just
assessing whether or model is able to
discriminate between risky and less
risky profile but it doesn't really care
about the the true
probabil the the actual probabil
predicted probability of survival okay
it doesn't care about the absolute value
of of the the the time to event or the
the probability of survival it just
cares about uh telling apart the
individuals that are more risky than
others okay so uh it's a ranking metric
the Brier score on the other hand is a
proper scoring rule which means that it
it will be minimum if the model outputs
the predicted probabilities that match
the actual uh probabilities from the
data generative process okay which is
never known uh but uh in a sense it's a
it's a very good way to assess the
quality of probabilistic models uh it's
a what we say it's a proper scoring rule
so I think the integrated Bri score is
the best uh way to assess the this kind
of survival model or integrated negative
L likelihood would be similarly good
U uh but still looking at the
concordance index is interesting because
for some applications we don't don't
really care about the the pro predicted
probab probabilities we just want to
rank what is the most likely what are
the most likely individual to to to
experience failure to for instance if
you're doing running a predictive
maintenance program and you have a
limited resources to send human experts
to investigate if the trucks are in good
conditions you want to send them to the
the riskiest trucks first and then once
they are completed the inspection they
can move on to the next truck for
instance but since you have a limited
number of repair people uh mechanicians
uh you don't really care about the
probabilities you just want to allocate
them the most
efficient in the best efficient way
possible okay so depending on your
business setting either metric makes
sense but from a statistical point of
view the IBS is richer okay so here you
have the the mathematical
details uh I won't go into the details
uh but it's important to note that the
the Brier score the time dependent Brier
score here depends on an estimate of the
sensoring distribution so here we did an
estimate of the sensoring distribution
that is independent of X using cap Mayer
and many people do that but in practice
we know that it's introducing a bias if
the sensoring distribution depends on X
if it has a statistical dependency of on
x so it's a bit of a chicken and X
problem because to actually estimate
this we need another kind of survival
model for the sensoring distribution
which is slightly different problem so
it's a bit weird because we need to
solve the problem twice to actually
judge whether a model is is good or not
uh but if we can make the assumption
that there is no statistical dependency
between sensoring and and the coet then
this is perfectly fine and for this data
set there this condition is actually
very because we generated it so we can
trust it for for this data set uh in a
more general setting it's it's more
complex
unfortunately um all right so then there
is a bunch of utility function so we do
a trend test split it's more complex
than usual uh because psychic survival
originally was causing
problems uh in the end we ended up
removing psych survival from this
tutorial but uh we we kept this strest
split function that is a bit
complex uh yeah I will skip the details
uh but basically we have our X
covariates or Y values those are the
binary uh binary indicators plus the
duration so it has two columns Y is the
data frame with two columns and X is the
data frame with the the CET uh and so we
do a trend test split basically uh then
uh we can estimate the survival curve
only on the training
set so here it's just the cap mayor for
the full all the individuals and then we
will consider basically that um we we
make a prediction that is the same for
all the individual and we predict the
survival curve for all individual in the
same way using the cap estimate so it's
going to be a
baseline
uh um and we need to make the
predictions for a reference grid that
that is going to be the same for all the
models that we are going to that we are
going to compare so we generate a Time
grid that is arbitrary with 300 time
points between uh some close to zero
minimum value and close to maximum
maximum value uh and we will in evaluate
uh the prediction for for the survival
at all those time points and then
compare different models okay so we we
predict the the the the survival
probabilities from the capan mayor at
the specific time points uh of our
evaluation grid okay and then we will
replicate these predictions many times
for all the the individuals in our test
St so it's a bit weird because here we
are we are not making individual
prediction we are replicating the same
prediction for everyone it's just a way
to uh to to compute a Baseline and then
we will compare conditional models
against that Baseline
later uh all right so since we have made
those prediction for those time points
for all our test points or test tracks
uh we can use from our hazardous Library
the Brier score U and compute the Brier
scores for all the time points in the
time grid and so let's plot this because
we have many values so for each
reference time
reference uh we compute whether or not
the the the probability predicted by
capla mayor
is good or not so if it's zero it means
that it's very good if it's large it
means that it's not not so good okay so
you see that for small time Horizon it's
very good it's very close to zero and it
makes sense because it's very easy to
predict that nearly 100% of the trucks
have not experienced fa failure after
one day for instance and it will be
mostly correct so it's it's kind of easy
to not make an error for small time
Horizon similarly for large time Horizon
You can predict that almost all of them
have have experienced the failure and it
would be a good prediction also however
in in the middle between those two
extremes where nearly all of them have
have are heaven threee and nearly all of
them have experienced the event you
don't know exactly how fast they will
experience the event in between those
two extremes okay and this is why uh the
the prer score is typically uh large for
medium uh for intermediate times okay
all right so we can summarize this error
curve by the area under the curve so we
integrate we integrate it through time
so it's basically an average uh between
a T and T Max of Interest so T in could
be zero TX could be the maximum observe
time uh Sometimes some survival models
will refuse to predict that t me or
nearly T Max so this is why we we use a
grid that is started bit later and and
stop a bit
before uh and then we have this value so
the IBS of our kapan mayor estimator
evaluated on the test set is
074 17 and4
174 uh so this value it's hard to to
interpret uh it's not a a fraction of
error it's not a percentage it's it's
just a value that should be that is
always positive and should be uh as
close to zero as possible for good
models uh and large for bad models uh
but even the best model uh should be non
zero the value will be non zero for the
for the best model because in practice
the the information that we have in X
does not give us a deterministic way to
uh predict uh the time to event it's
very rarely the case that we can
deterministically predict the exact time
to event only from the features like for
instance if you consider the features
that we had
here
uh yes we just have uh the driver skill
for instance it could be on a test uh um
like a a driving test uh so it's an
assessment of the driving skills the
brand of the truck the track model the
usage rate for those four values it's
not possible to give a precise
uh to be 100% of the time precisely
predict the duration to the to the
failure event even if you ignore the
sensoring thing okay uh there is some
Randomness in the uh in the failures
that is not explained by the the
covariates that that we observe uh and
that we we can record okay so this is
why even for the best model the IBS will
never be zero okay it will be strictly
on zero but we don't know what is the
IBS of the best model because we don't
know the best model in general here we
could compute it and we will actually do
it in the end of The Notebook um but uh
because we know the data Al generative
process but in a real life setting it's
not possible okay so I will go a bit
faster uh so uh we can uh compute also
the integrated Brier score for another
Baseline which is a survival function
that start at 100% and goes to zero at
the end of the time grid and decrease
linearly so it's a complete ba it's a
it's a baseline that is completely
arbitrary uh but we just want to check
that the the prior score for that
arbitrary Baseline is
worse uh than for capl estimate okay so
the cap mayor estimate ignore predict
the same survival cure for everybody but
it's still predicting better than a bad
Baseline okay than this guy okay an
arbory Baseline so if this is the best
model basically that you can do if you
ignore the values in X okay so here
maybe you do not have that in the
version of The Notebook but I just
wanted to plot the the two curve so I
added that uh so this is the capan mayor
curve in Orange and in blue the the
linear Base Line and you see that the
cap mayor curve even if you predict the
same curve for every run it's already
much better from an IBS point of view
than an arbitrary function like this
okay so we can also evaluate the
concordance index which is as I said
previously rank the ranking ranking
power evaluation of the models so here
you have the the details if you're
interested
in but here because I predict every for
all the model the
same
uh the the same uh uh
values
uh I expect to observe
0.5 uh concordance index for for my two
my two Bas lines because they are not
discriminative at all they predict the
same survival function for everyone okay
so we will use the implementation from
lifelines and actually here there is a
typo it's not from Lifeline metric
import concordance index it's from
Lifeline
utils uh that you you need to edit it
import concordance index and the
implementation of concordance index in
lifelines works with hazards so we need
to to uh to convert a survival estimate
into a hazard or risk estimate so this
is why we have this loss function here
so it's
a uh not loss function it's
um yeah python function that converts
survival function to accumulated risk
estimate
okay uh so we can run this I forgot to
execute this and we we get the 0.5 value
because uh we predict uh the same Caper
curve for everyone so it's not
discriminative so it's it's just a
sanity check
so uh just for this the the rest of the
notebook I will record all my evaluation
into this survival analysis evaluator
and I will add progressively all the
models using this uh and pass the the
predictions and uh this way we can uh
compute the metric the IBS and the c
Index and display the bror the Brier
error uh the time dependent prior errors
to compare if some models are below
others and so here you see that the c
Index is the same is 0.5 for the two
constant two constant Bas line like and
the IBS is better for the C mayor
because the the probabilities that are
predicted are more calibrated are well
calibrated and so the the Bier score is
lower everywhere in the end it's not the
case I'm not uh not sure why the
constant linear would be better than cap
maybe it has to do with numerical
integration or something I I'm not sure
exactly way uh that is not
stable there is something weird here but
uh probably it's something that we can
numerical error that we should
ignore I would have expected that the
Range Line should be below okay so now
that we have our unconditional b line uh
we actually want to do predictive
survival analysis so we will start to
use for instance C proportional Hazard
which is very popular way to do to do a
a prediction of Hazard given X values so
I won't explain the details on how it
works but there is an implementation in
lifelines and uh we can wrap it to make
it work in a in a more psych learish
setting uh so here let's look at the
covariates so this is a data frame the
input values so we will uh pre-process
those values using this simple
pre-processor so it's using the column
Transformer from Psychic learn it will
uh use um transform those two columns uh
brand and truck model because those are
categorical values with string labels uh
we need to one not encode them to get
numerical description of of those values
using different expended features and
for the numerical columns we can leave
them as such so we use a remainder
equals path
through uh so let's use this and you see
that we get an ire array as a result uh
with those values so in recent versions
of psyit learn it's also possible to to
say set out output do not write this I
just show you uh transform equal
pendas uh and you you would get a data
frame so you could understand what the
column names uh mean uh okay so you see
that for the the two uh one not encoded
brand and truck models they have been
expanded into more features and those
features are binaries zero and one so
Dem variables okay and the numerical
features are uh concatenated at the end
unchanged okay so I I will go back to
default because I'm not sure if
lifelines would work probably I'm not
sure so let's go back to n it's safer uh
okay so then we will import the co
proportional hazard fter from lifelines
uh we have a small wrapper here to make
it such that it has the same API as
hazardous and as psyit survival
so that we can use the same metric
object on those okay uh lifelines also
has different psych wrapper but uh it it
has its own way of computing survival
metric so this we didn't want to to use
that for that reason so okay so we use
our our own wrapper here and then we can
make make it part of a pyit pipeline and
we can fit it on the train data and on
the sensor train data okay so this is
the sensor data
frame uh so there is a warning here I
don't understand why uh didn't have time
to
investigate uh I just wanted to to show
that this is the sensor data okay there
is the the binary indicator whether or
not we have actually observed the event
and if it's false it's
sensor all right so we can use lifelines
uh now that it has been fitted to
predict the survival function and we do
that for all the time Horizons of
interest on the test set okay and then
we will be able to uh to compare that
model predictions to the base length
Okay so before doing uh the actual
numerical evaluation of the model we can
just do a qualitative evaluation of the
prediction so here we plot the predicted
survival functions for the first five
individuals in the test set and so you
see that individual zero is much more
risky than the others like the model
estimates that it has uh much lower
likelihood of survival at a short time
Horizon compared to for instance
individual three and individual four
which have much larger uh survival
probabilities for all all the things by
construction uh Cox proportional
Hazard
um uh will plot lines that cannot really
cross okay so it's a it's a a limitation
of this model that it
it's not rich enough to to model
situations where
one individual would be risky at the
beginning and less Lis at the end than
others uh so all the the the the the
model this the individual are predicted
to have the same kind of risk profile
over time it's just that some would be
much more risky than others okay so
apparently there's a
question
[Music]
uh okay no no question just comments
okay
uh I don't think so okay ask questions
in the question area if there are
questions just to make sure uh all right
so
uh so
yeah we could try to link to to relate
what is specific to Blue and would
explain uh the the higher
risk uh based on the name we could try
to guess uh for instance it's a cheap
brand so and we said on aggregate it was
more likely to to fail the driver skill
is also very low compared to the other
so maybe those two features explain uh
and the the usage rates is still
significantly high so it kind of makes
sense that the model predicts that this
will fail first okay
um
uh so we could read this plot in
different way either as regression so
for instance uh the probability uh for
50% of of similar drivers to experience
this event uh the time I mean for 50% of
the similar drivers to experience this
event so here it should be much shorter
for this one so could be read as a
regression model or it could be read as
a classification model vertically if you
consider different time Horizon the
probability of survival at different
times
okay uh okay so there is an exercise but
we are running close to
the just have 10 minutes left uh so I
will just show you the
solution uh so here the the exercise was
about uh relating the the coefficients
of the model to the coar names and then
to see the the influence the statistical
relationship the Association statistical
Association of each individual coet to
the predicted
hazards uh and based on the coefficient
of the lifeline Co proportional Hazard
model okay and so if a coefficient is
negative it means that the driver skill
has a negative influence on the hazard
it means that the better the skill of
the driver the lower the risk of
experiencing the event and that makes
sense uh you see that the branch ships
and Rober actually have no such big
impact and apparently the different
kinds of model based on the co
proportional Hazard model are more
influential than the actual brand brand
okay and the usage rate uh kind of it's
kind of expected but the more you use
the truck the the higher uh the risk
failure if you do not use it uh you have
a very low probability of experiencing a
failure the truck doesn't run on the
road okay um finally we can quantify the
metrics so we we put the prediction uh
in our evaluator and then we can compare
uh with the the before the the other
Baseline and you see that uh this new
model the discriminative model is much
better than before because first on the
c Index it's better than chance so it it
can actually tell apart risky driver
from others uh more than uh randomly
better than randomly and the IBS metric
the interrogated Brer score is lower and
on average you can see that it's
uniformly lower except for those large
values so here there is probably a
calibration problem uh for for the large
time Horizon but there are very few data
points here so the the model should be
quite uncertain and so even this
estimate of the error should be quite
uncertain we did not put confidency
interval we could compute bootstrap
confidency intervals for this uh we kept
the code simple okay so there was
another exercise exercise here which is
to enrich the feature set for the Cox
proportional fitter by using uh
components from psyit learn such as the
spline transformer for numerical
features and the nrom
kernel approximation that would kind of
simulate kernel support Vector machine
basically uh but by doing feature
processing and so the the spline feature
Transformer is applied to the numerical
features for cical features we still use
the one encoder and those two features
groups of features will be concatenated
and on the result of the concatenation
we expand them to three dimensional
space 300 dimensional Space by
approximating what we call a sign order
polinomial K so that should make it
possible to capture interactions between
features and nonlinear interactions
between features and also add an XIs
align inductive prior to the numerical
variable which is usually a good idea if
there are thresold defect for instance
for the skill or for the usage rate that
might happen so we can use the displine
Transformer to do that uh so let's uh
try to fit this model so it might take
take a bit more time because it's more
complex model with many more features
than
previously uh and uh then we will
evaluate uh the results so there is a
question
uh what's a good way to download this
notebook set of example uh uh so if you
look at the the URL uh it's a GitHub
report uh it's a GitHub pages that is
linked to a GitHub report so U let me
show
you uh actually it's not visible in the
URL
uh it's actually on V Mader
uh
GitHub and then uh there should be so
there is the survival analysis
Benchmark uh well yeah actually this is
a good uh a good way to do to get it so
this is the non Jupiter light non
Jupiter light version so in the notebook
so the previous version that we did uh
and also include the psych survival uh
thing so it's actually a a richer
version of this tutorial okay and uh so
it's on soda in I will copy and paste
this in the
chat okay and
uh and so and there are additional
things in particular the the the python
code to use to generate the data
set all right uh in the Jupiter live
version if you dig up on V some
GitHub you will find these GitHub pages
and you can work it out from there it's
also a good example if you are
interested in hosting your own Jupiter
light setting you can have a look at the
configuration files okay so in the end
it uh managed to run and you see that
it's better than the Cox proportional
when we do the polinomial feature
processing it's significantly
better uh it doesn't seem so but it's
actually quite significant if you you we
didn't have time to do run cross
validation but it's I'm I'm pretty sure
that it's significantly better so doing
this kind of nonlinear feature
engineering is kind of mitigating some
of the limitation of the linear Co
proportional asard model uh it's both
more discriminative and it's still
better calibrated or it's better in
general taking both discrimination and
calibration into account it's still
weird this in the end that it's uh it's
not very good but okay so let's uh fit
also our gradient boosting model from
hazardous uh so I want to explain how it
works internally uh can
explain we'll write a paper on this at
some point in the future to explain but
you can have a look at the source code
of hazardous also so
hazardous
uh I'll put the link in the
chat
the source code give you more details so
it's some kind of experimental
repository we know that it's not perfect
uh it's not the best model that we can
think of there are problems so we plan
to fix them in the future but it's still
better than Cox proportional Hazard on
on this data set so here are predicted
survival functions so because we use
gradient boosted trees it predicts
piecewise
constant uh surviv functions which is
not ideal you would have preferred maybe
smooth functions but what is interested
is that for this two drivers three and
four now we can predict surveil function
that cross which was not possible with
Co proportional Hazard by Design okay
even with the polinomial features okay
and furthermore since we are using
gradient boosted trees it can model uh
interactive interactions nonlinear
interactions between functions so it's a
better model uh it's more expressive and
if you evaluate it you see that it's
actually uh it's the same level here for
the small data set but if you run this
which is the same analysis with a larger
version of the data set it will might
take a bit more time and we are running
out of of time but you will see uh that
it's better than the polinomial thing
okay so unfortunately I think the time
is up so if you have questions uh feel
free to ask them in the chat and I can
stay a bit longer